Hey YouTubers it's Charlie, this is game of
thrones episode five video some really cool
moments done in slightly different ways so
I'll explain what the differences are as we
work through WTF moments this week and giving
away signed copies of these for pros and dance
with dragons so I did it in the giveaway is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this video
I'll announce the winner in my Q&A tomorrow
so careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet on the new top seven moments
just to give me a little extra room just like
last week so. Number seven the death of Barristan
Selmy Barristan the bold this is a real bummer
so supposedly the actor was doing interviews
last week talking about being dead so there
there were some minor spoilers especially
with the promo they released everyone knew
going into this season that they'd be killing
a character that still alive in the book is
one of the big points of divergence from the
show Barristan Selmy is going to be a POB
chapter and wins a winter so if you're huge
Barristan Selmy fan just hold your breath
till the book is released and you be fine
isn't it interesting how Hizdahr dislikes
slowly walks in the background is the nurses
ruminating on his death he prostrated himself
so much in this episode that there is got
to be something going on with his character
a lot of people think that this woman might
be the harpy because in the books the biggest
theory is is that the green grace is the harpy
but the green grace is in on the TV show they
don't have that character doing something
different Hizdahr could still turn out to
be the harpy or the person controlling the
harpy is or could be a nonissue on the show
there is now a gaping hole in Daenerys's circle
of advisers and it actually causes some problems during
the episode because she seems a lot of help
Daenerys sitting advisers also kinda works
well with Maester amen feeling so sorry for
that was another big book related moment in
the episode in the books Maester amen has
a speech just like this one is talking to
Samwell about Daenerys being alone but he
feels like he is too old to go help her it
was a subtle shout out to the Citadel in old
town so we could be seeing that on the show
just in case him in a way to talk about that
as expected Samwell is like slowly learning
more about the white walkers and Stannis is
really interested in that which I think is
really cool I love that he gave that shot
out I hear you kill the white walker he also
gave his dad a big shout out it just shows
you that it's that much easier to get Stannis's
perspective that it is to get a hug from them
on to number six Daenerys rounds up all the
leaders in the noble house the Marine this
is one of the first moments in the episode
where they on her a moment from the books
by doing something slightly different Quentin
Martel has a minor storyline in the books
but the show isn't doing him I think this
moment here with this person getting roasted
by one of the nurses dragons is a mosh to
his storyline and the books there were a number
of other moments in the episode that did things
like that so that's what I think this is think
of this is like a Quentin Martel seen on to
number five John still wants to bring the
Wildlings from Hardhome down to the wall Maester
amen gives him a little bit of a bomb killed
the boy so that the man can live this is part
of the larger arc of John Snow learning to
be a leader the same thing is happening with
the nurse in Marine years she is learning
to be a queen Maester amen tells in the job
is going to suck, you could also say the same
for Daenerys being Queen of all those people
it is totally going to suck for her the title
killed the boy was one of the best things
about the episode you you could apply it in
metaphorical ways to what's going on with
Jon Snow he needs to kill the boy inside
him and you can apply it in a literal context
Ramzi Bolton wants to kill the boy inside
foul ball the thing you have Olie here who
absolutely hates the fact that John Snow is
doing this with the Wildlings Hardhome there's
no way John is going to kill all a but that
doesn't mean that he is not to die somehow
kill the boy and to be clear Olie is actually
mistaken the thins are the ones that killed
his family they lived way up here north of
where the freefall live genealogically there
completely separate group there people are
actually more genetically pure descendents
of the first men they didn't interbreed as
much with people from other places in the
world onto number for Sansa and Dion's Reunion
so now we come to see where the Miranda plot
is going she is a greyscale creek without
a paddle so what can she do but create chaos
the place where she met Sansa about the broken
tower that's actually the place where brain
got pushed out the window by Jamie because
Twincest there were so many meta-moments in
the scene to it's like your thinking you back
about that season one moment in your thinking
about what the servant woman said to Sansa
you know light a candle at the top if you
need help which ties to the Brienne storyline
where she's hiding out in winter town near
Winterfell trying to help Sansa it's really
hard to tell where reeks storyline is going
right now I think he's genuinely afraid for
her her motions are much more complex like
just waves of anger just wash over her the
minute she recognizes him what I'm really
hoping to see if they like the on kill Ramsey
to save Sansa and then Sansa does something
to kill Greek it would be really fun to to
see Sansa push Maranda out the window that
brain got pushed out of the minute they both
looked up at that window I just thought somebody
has to get push data that this season so Myranda
mission accomplished there is now chaos Rick
is probably going to try and do something
to atone for what he did Sansa whose acquitting
yourself quite nicely amongst all her enemies
is probably just going to see what she can
do to survive and then you have Brienne who's
going to try and help out to suck you like
all these things that Winterfell working together
and now there's actually some added chaos
because Fat Walda is pregnant with a boy onto
number three Ramsey versus his unborn brother
so many funny moments between Ramsey and his
father when they had been seen on your air
until someone better comes along suddenly
the title killed the boy takes on a more literal
context I definitely think that Ramsey is
going to try and do something to Fout Wald
the I think Bruce's speech about Ramsey's
mother explains why the show wants you to
think of him as a villain that is if you didn't
think the red wedding made him a villain it
just you know characters kill other characters
it doesn't necessarily mean that game of thrones
is the show has a true hero and a true villain
on a character like this fondly remembers
raping a peasant woman then almost killing
her when she brought their baby to his gait
there can be no doubt that this character
has to die in a really terrible way the North
remembers maybe some will catch him on the
shooter wouldn't it be funny if Ramsey pulled
the Tyrion and killed Fat Walda the and his
father he is the air right now so hee hee
be good to go if they were both dead onto
number two Daenerys reopens the fighting peds
and tells Hizdahr that she is going to marry
him this is another small departure from the
books so Daenerys does reopen the fighting
peds and she does get betrothed to Hizdahr
but it's more of a choice put her in the books
the show is just giving her a little more
agency Misandei says that she always relies
on her visors in the books she does have like
a lot more people advising her I like the
way the show is doing this it is showing that
Daenerys is choosing to enter this eyes open
in the book she knows she has to marry Hizdahr
but she's much more reluctant about it on
the show it looks like she's going to dominate
him and finally my number one WTF moment Tyrion
and Sir Jorah do the young group storyline
in old Valyria is a whole Lotta meta-things
going on with this. Jorah seen at the end
first they go into the ruins of old Valyria
which isn't something that the books does
So that's a change but it's really fun change
it's like showing us the lands of always winter
last season that's the way I thought about
that scene showing us a place that they talk
about in the books but the we don't actually
go to in the books the stone member also part
of that in the books but this is basically
taking the place of is the young group storyline
so Tyrion is traveling with the young group
characters on the shy made down the runway
and he falls in and John Connington yanks
him out just like Sir Jorah did but in the
process contracts grayscale just like Jorah
did so Sir Jorah is, taking that from John
Connington storyline huge WTF and Tyrion craps
his pants when he sees Drogon flying overhead
he also has a vision of Drogon in the books
but it's in a slightly different context since
we don't know if Jorah and Tyrion are going
to make it to Marine unscathed and I can go
too deep into his storyline from the books
so just wait till after next week potency
another Lottie asking you know what is grayscale
how does it work really like your skin and
your internal organs like your soft tissues
they all just hardened so that it looks like
stone so like as your internal organs start
to stone over so to speak you slowly lose
the ability to function your bodies to start
shutting down so when they say stone men of Valyria
think of it is being like a really serious
version of a leper colony you can't touch
anyone or you give it to them just over here
by yourselves and leave us alone the really
fun thing go about them going to the ruins
of Valyria is is Tyrion has an uncle one of
Tywin's brothers that went to the ruins of
Valyria looking for the ancestral blade of
the Lannisters it's called bright war and
his uncle was never seen again I was a little
disappointed he to get a shot on the episode
but I but I totally understand and not doing
it so here's my big question for you guys
what was your favorite moment from the episode
and what do you think it's gonna happen to
Sir Jorah now that he has grayscale Stannis
explained to Shireen the he was able to halt
the progress of the grayscale is scarred Shireen's
face for life but he was able to stop it before
he killed her so Jorah isn't necessarily sentenced
to death as much is the changing of barges
stuff from the books you you can see how there
were like specific moments where they were
trying to do both things even though they
did them in slightly different ways I feel
like it done a good job so far building momentum
with each episode each new week things have
gotten progressively crazier and crazier until
finally were an old Valyria we see grayscale
and we see Drogon was freaking huge you just
let me know if you agree you know do you feel
like they're building momentum with each episode
sometimes they don't always stick the landing
like you know there's always big moments in
the finales but sometimes non-finale episodes
just come together as a whole and end up being
a little bit better than actual finales so
don't forget about the book giveaway on announce
the winner of that tomorrow my Q&A video, while you wait for that to post you can click here to learn
all about Lyanna Stark's history and you can
click here for last week's episode thank you
so much for watching, everybody high five
and I'll see you tomorrow!